comme tous les mercredis cette partie
cinéma se poursuit avec vous Céline
Charles on va faire le point sur
l'actualité c'est sorti ciné de la
semaine le premier film que vous nous
proposez ce soir c'est bien sûr le
nouveau film de Steven Spielberg
évidemment on aurait pu croire qu'après
76 ans et presque 40 longs métrages le
réalisateur américain aurait déjà tout
raconté et bien non il nous prouve le
contraire avec son nouveau film The
fabuleman après James gredin Armageddon
time c'est à son tour de livrer une
partie de sa vie regardez si tu arrêtes
de faire des films ta mère sera
inconsolable
je suis perdu je sais plus quoi faire
fais ce que ton cœur t'ordonne
[Musique]
est-ce que tu as préféré
alors comme on vient de le voir le
réalisateur de iti ou bien Jurassic Park
mais en scène dans ce nouveau film sa
propre enfance et sa propre adolescence
dans l'Amérique moyenne des années 50 et
60 il y aborde sa passion dévorante pour
le cinéma sa relation parfois
conflictuelle avec une famille autant
couleur et sa vie d'adolescents avec ses
hauts et ses bas un film touchant et
plein de vie où on apprend vraiment à
découvrir comment Steven est devenu
Spielberg finalement pendant son enfance
on continue cette sélection avec un
drame romantique oui ça s'appelle arrête
avec tes mensonges de Olivier Peillon
c'est une adaptation du livre à succès
éponyme de Philippe Besson on y retrouve
Guillaume de Tonquédec dans le rôle de
Stéphane Bellecour un romancier qui
accepte de retourner dans sa ville
natale pour y parrainer un événement
après avoir juré de ne jamais y
retourner il va rencontrer Lucas
interprété par le petit-fils de
Jean-Paul Belmondo Victor Belmondo Lucas
est le fils de Thomas qui n'est autre
que le premier amour de Stéphane le
romancier alors qu'il n'avait que 17 ans
regardez
il fait comment mon père
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et toi aussi
seule fois aussi lumineux à la télé
c'était qui pour vous
abandonné du jour au lendemain comme
pour toi sans un mot sans une
explication et dans ce film on va donc
se plonger dans les souvenirs de cette
histoire d'amour avorter mais jamais
oublier une adaptation autobiographique
autobiographique qui je suis sûre vous
fera vous émouvoir
Belmondo effectivement le portrait
quasiment craché mais en tout cas et
ensemblance avec Jean-Paul Belmondo on
va terminer avec un documentaire et oui
Grégory je vous propose un documentaire
pour clore cette sélection documentaire
animalier pour être plus précise les
gardiennes de la planète du réalisateur
Jean Albert lièvre nous compte la vie et
l'histoire des baleines et plus
particulièrement leur chant un système
de communication unique au monde alors
le documentaire est très immersif il
nous plonge vraiment dans l'eau aux
côtés des cétacés les images comme on
peut le voir sont saisissantes et je
pense que c'est d'ailleurs plus
grandiose sur écran de cinéma le film
évidemment un enjeu écologique en toile
de fond il a l'alerte mais toujours avec
optimisme sur la faune essentielle à
notre survie que l'on est partiellement
en train de détruire petit plus ce
documentaire est raconté par un
yvelinois un certain Jean Dujardin
moi personnellement ça sera le nouveau
Steven Spielberg vous avez fait votre
choix
arrête avec tes mensonges voilà moi
c'est ça ce sera ça aussi je pensais
franchement oui ça pourrait nous
intéresser du coup le documentaire c'est
ça exactement
s'il y a un film à sélectionner les
images et l'esthétique il a donné un
côté vraiment poétique en fait c'est les
baleines qui racontent l'histoire la
voix de voilà de Jean Dujardin donc je
pense que ça peut être très immersif
d'être en plus ça a été pris au 4 coins
du monde dans plusieurs pays on est
vraiment dans l'eau donc c'est
passionnant je pense à découvrir à ne
pas manquer cette semaine merci Céline
pour cette sélection